all right it's that time of year again
yes i didn't do one of these last year
because i was like i didn't watch enough
movies and now i feel like i've watched
just as many films this year as i did
last year but i want to do this but i
will say i have full reviews on all the
movies on this list so if you want to
see my more in-depth thoughts you can go
check out those reviews this video is
going to be my quick thoughts on these
movies because you don't want to be here
forever you got better things to do i
feel like this is the part where i'm
supposed to be like oh film is
subjective these are just my opinions
are not going to be your opinions blah
blah blah but you know that
you know that so i'm going to finish off
this intro by saying if you wanted a
video that shows what my casual ass like
this year well you've come to the right
place enough the intro [ __ ] let's
get this party started these are my top
10 favorite movies of the year 20210
starting off this list is a movie that
on any other year maybe it wouldn't have
made the list but this is 2021 my friend
so free guy is on the list free guy
simply put is a better matrix
resurrections movie than the matrix
resurrections ryan reynolds being his
basic ryan reynolds character absolutely
but it had likable characters characters
you get behind not only does it ask
questions about consciousness and
intelligence artificial or otherwise but
it also addresses a lot of the shitty
marketing tactics that we see a lot of
video game companies use these days free
guy is one of those movies it had no
business being as good as it was but it
was a damn good time number nine
next up i am an edgar wright fan i
generally enjoy what he does such is the
case with last night in soho simply put
last night in soho was a unique
experience it was a lot that worked it
was part crime drama part mystery part
horror part thriller just cracked my
knuckle don't know if you heard that
interesting premise and there was a
point in this movie i was like is this
movie gonna have payoff and it did
strong performances some curveballs
throughout kept me guessing this is one
of those movies that shows the range of
edgar wright's filmmaking it was unique
i can't say i had another experience
this year like last night in soho
next up king richard if there was a
movie that was created and fashioned
with heart i would say it was king
richard will smith was getting a lot of
the oscar chatter when this movie came
out there are about four people in this
movie i feel should have that same
chatter but most importantly it was a
good family story you know it's the
story of venus and serena williams but
the family dynamic that made these
tennis legends you really get the
feeling that they love their father they
love their mother they love their family
and they wanted to give them the shine
and that warms my heart it really does
if there is a movie this year where
people are like oh i'm looking for a
feel-good family movie i always point to
king richard
number seven
all right get into that territory of
didn't know what to expect from this
movie and was really pleasantly
surprised cop shot cop shop was just a
damn good time doesn't hurt that i
didn't watch the trailer i had no idea
what to expect from this movie but turns
out it was a kick ass good time great
performances all around gerard butler
and frank grillo they were they were
having a blast with the movie and not in
that well they were having fun but the
movie sucked kind of way no i felt the
movie was a damn good time i have a soft
spot for those movies that take place in
one location and people are trying to
get in there and kill people very
assault on precinct 13 if it felt like
assault on priesting 13 was adapted from
a graphic novel kick-ass good time and
huge surprise this year cop shot
number six
speaking of kick ass surprise nobody
also on this list nobody is john wick of
john wick remort grounded in reality you
know more vulnerable more human per se
but also as much as i used john wick as
a comparison springboard to describe to
people what nobody is it's not a john
wick ripoff in a world where john wick
and the equalizer came before nobody
nobody still feels like its own thing it
feels unique bob odenkirk has great
timing whether it be dramatic whether it
be comedic and also apparently kick-ass
i thought it was a good telling of that
guy he's a normal guy he's a
neighborhood guy you know the white
picket fence the sprinkler
that kind of life also he has a past and
he will wreck your [ __ ] i enjoyed the
hell out of nobody what can i say from
the moment i got out of this movie i was
like
that's a good shot at being on the top
ten and here it is
number five
next up val it feels a little weird
having val this low on the list when it
was one of my what two awesome taculars
awesome taculars this year my ratings
are jokes don't get hung up on them you
know that by now but here val is and it
was inevitable that a movie like val
would eventually happen one day but it
just it would take all the stars to
align you needed an actor who would
become a well-known actor that through
the course of his career
filmed his life and his career behind
the scenes with a camcorder in an age
where not a lot of people had camcorders
and then you needed someone to cut that
footage together and make a documentary
if not a documentary just his life
through his eyes kind of scenario and
here we are we have val it's a great
look at the fact that no matter who the
celebrity is actor director youtube
personality instagram personality
whoever they are they're still human you
know this is very human look there are a
lot of actors out there with youtube
channels but the fact that youtube is a
thing and they got on youtube after
youtube was a thing it leaves you
feeling well is this real is this really
them the fact that all this footage of
val kilmer was filmed before there was a
youtube just made for his own personal
archives has that feeling of this is the
guy i dug it
number four
next up spider-man no way home i'm a
huge spider-man fan 90s spider-man kid
you know that spider-man animation in
the 90s
loved it spider-man no way home is a
celebration of spider-man to me and his
fan service done right it's fan service
that works with the characters with the
plots woven into the narrative is not
just blatant for the sake of member
berries there's a reason this movie's
made over a billion dollars now it's
hitting spider-man fans on a deeper
level than just the superficial
fanservice level it's also a hard lesson
for hollywood that's for sure it's one
of those if you build it they will come
kind of scenarios and i had a great time
with this movie it was
more than what i hoped it could have
been
number three
all right we're getting into the top
three now look at this is dune on the
list yeah as i was shuffling this list
around everything within the top five
was number one at some point just to see
how it looked how it felt and dune was
there and if dune was a complete movie
it probably would have been number one
but it's not a complete movie it's it's
one third of a movie not in that
fellowship of the ring kind of way we're
talking like one-third of fellowship of
the ring kind of way but as it stands i
walked out of dune going okay denis
villeneuve he gets it i love the world i
love the craftsmanship i love what he's
building i have nothing but hope for the
next dune having one third of a movie on
this list on the top 10 just shows that
optimism is still alive in this dark
heart of mine it was a visual opera a
visual epic and i just i'm salivating
for that time in the future where i have
the entirety of denny villeneuve's dune
all six hours or whatever it's gonna be
and i just sit there and i just kind of
don't move
number two
next up the green knight green knight is
a little more pretentious than i usually
have on my list but damn if i didn't dig
this movie green knight is a character
odyssey a character quest it's a fantasy
story with very down-to-earth fantasy
elements but man did this movie stick to
landing with that last montage leading
up to the ending is there a beat-off
scarf yeah we all have at least one this
movie was pure fantasy craftsmanship
from the moment i saw it to now it
remained high on my list i suggest
anyone watch this movie at least once
it's worth a watch
number one
and this is number one in this past year
2021 there was one movie in which i was
able to watch it back to back twice in
one weekend all four hours both times
locked in never got bored neither did my
family zack snyder's justice league it's
a movie that really worked for me that's
the best time i had in a movie this year
part of that is the fact that i
appreciate that it even happened
absolutely but this movie validated the
zack snyder vision it's one of those
things where zack snyder showed the
world yeah when studios stay out of it
and i'm just able to do my thing maybe i
can make a pretty solid justice league
universe that was great because i
doubted the [ __ ] out of the guy i was
like does this guy know what he's doing
now i feel bad for thinking that i want
to see the snyder verse go on i want to
see the next chapter will that happen i
don't know
but damn i really want it the fact that
i want to see the snyder verse continue
after watching this movie shows what it
did for my perception of the dc universe
this may be surprising for some but the
reasons are actually very simple and it
just comes down to enjoyment how long i
can engage with a movie and not get
bored there are very few movies in
existence in the history of cinema in
which i can put in engage for four hours
and not get bored at all zack snyder's
justice league is one of those movies
one of the few
of the couple and i can't say that about
any other movie on this list and that's
why zack snyder's justice league remains
my favorite moviegoing experience of
2021 and that is all beside the fact not
having zack snyder's justice league on
this list would in fact be an
injustice
so there you go those are my top 10
favorite movies of the year 2021 that i
personally watch i get it there are a
lot of movies i didn't watch and nothing
will change that it's the way it is
every year but i'm only one person in
this big playground known as the
youtubes the internets i know you got
your list too so how about you what are
your top 10 favorite movies of the year
2021 whatever they are whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you